oh là là là là ma lui nous a quittés un
géant sont est allé un peu trop tôt
peut-être mais c'est la vie ainsi va la
vie
évidemment tout le monde connaît ma
lutte banque ou comme un excellent un
grand saxophoniste mais il n'y a
peut-être pas beaucoup de gens qui
savent qu'il était un excellent pianiste
avant de le connaître en tant que
saxophoniste qui l'avons connu le
pianiste quelle occasion de
m'accompagner d'ailleurs plusieurs fois
à l'olympia et dans différentes
manifestations avec gzip légitimus et
même une pas dans un grand concert
organisé par gisèle baca que je salue au
passage et paul dans lequel il a eu
l'occasion de m'accompagner à pelleter
de pianiste ce que je retiens surtout
c'est qu'en dehors de sa qualité de
musicien d'excellents musiciens
c'est un homme d'une grande humilité
d'une très grande joie de vivre et d'un
rib extraordinaire mah lui nous ne
t'oublierons pas bon voyage et à la
prochaine
parce que nous tout obligé passait pas
la caméra